one thing that you've said that i know
that really hit me
was the goal is not to do business with
everybody that needs what you have the
goal is to
do business with people who believe what
you believe now i love that
right so believe me
the emotional part of me loves that the
practical part of me says
but what about when people say well
that's cute that's nice but
can i really be that picky business is
that easy that i can just do business
with people that believe what i believe
yes why how
okay so um i do believe that i believe
that to the core of my being that we
should
work very very hard to only do business
with people who believe what we believe
and reject business
from people who don't believe what we
believe and
i'm sometimes accused of being naive
and have been told yes but you can
afford to do that simon
you know i can't afford to do that and
the answer is i've been doing this for
the beginning since the beginning um
when i didn't have two pennies to rub
together
i would turn down business and the
reason is
is and don't get me wrong it's hard and
sometimes you do have to take the
business because you have
bills to pay the goal is not to get it
lopsided i had a real experience it's a
true story
of somebody who'd heard about my work
back in the early days of start with y
and he called me up and he says i've
heard good things about you from
whoever recommended me he says these
were the exact words he said he says
convince me why i should hire you
and my answer was don't
and the reason is simple anybody who
says convince me
is not is not somebody who believes what
i believe
and the ones that i would say yes to or
people who came up to me and said you
know
your stuff is interesting i don't think
it's all right i think
some of you got some things wrong but i
think it's
really really interesting i think we
could do something together those are
the people i want to work with
there's an old zen buddhist saying which
is how you do anything is how you do
everything
so if somebody is going to force me to
convince them why i should
work with them then every piece of
advice i give them they're going to
force me
to convince them why i am making this
recommendation
where does trust come in whereas when
there's
a shared set of values and beliefs um
trust builds uh uh deeper
so that when i say i think i think you
should try this they go huh
if you say so there's trust
um and it also keeps me to a high
standard because i know this person
does trust me so not to mention the fact
that those people just more fun to work
with
you know i work with fantastic people
because i chose to work with fantastic
people
i i don't have any clients that suck the
life out of me
because i said no right from the from
the get-go
[Applause]
and i'll add one more point you don't
have to do this
i'm not telling you everybody has to do
this it's simply a choice
um uh if you want to say yes to
everything
be my guest it's not my business it's
your business and do what you want with
it
this is how i've chosen to live my life
and run my business